produisez-vous un travail de moins bonne qualité ?
Je ne le pense pas, et les propos
de Charles Eames déclarant
qu'il avait conscience d'être
dans la contrainte,
mais pas dans le compromis, m'ont toujours encouragé.
Il est vrai que la distinction entre une contrainte
et un compromis est très subtile,
mais elle est au cœur de mon attitude face au travail.
Vous vous souvenez de ça ?
L'annuaire. Je la laisse
pour la séquence nostalgie.
Ce sont les premiers essais, au milieu des années 1970,
de la police Bell Centennial que j'ai créée
pour les annuaires américains,
c'était ma première expérience de police numérique,
et un sacré baptême.
Destinée, donc, aux annuaires,
pour être imprimée à une taille minuscule sur du papier journal
par des presses à rotatives ultra-rapides
avec une encre au kérosène et à la suie.
Ce n'est pas un environnement hospitalier
pour un concepteur de typographie.
Le défi fut donc de créer la police
qui conviendrait le mieux
à ces terribles conditions de production.
C'était les prémices de la typographie numérique.
Je devais dessiner tous les caractères à la main
sur du papier millimétré -
Bell Centennial existait en 4 graisses -
pixel par pixel, puis les encoder trame par trame
pour le clavier.
Cela a pris 2 ans, mais j'ai énormément appris.
Ces lettres ont l'air mâchées
par le chien ou autre,
mais les pixels évidés aux intersections
des fûts ou aux angles
sont le résultat de mon observation de l'influence
de l'encre imprimée sur du papier bon marché
et de ma réaction en adaptant la police.
Ces étranges pattes de mouches sont conçues pour compenser
les effets indésirables de l'échelle
et des procédés de production.
Au départ, AT&T voulait
imprimer ses annuaires en Helvetica,
mais, comme Erik Spiekermann le dit
dans le film Helvetica, si vous l'avez vu,
les lettres Helvetica ont été conçues pour
favoriser au maximum la similitude entre elles.
Ce n'est pas un bon choix pour une lisibilité en petite taille.
C'est très élégant sur une diapositive.
J'ai dû différencier les formes
de ces chiffres autant que possible pour Bell Centennial
en ouvrant les formes de cette façon, ainsi,
en bas de cette diapositive.
A présent, nous arrivons au milieu des années 1980,
les premiers jours des polices numériques détourées,
la technologie vectorielle.
A cette époque, il y avait un problème
de taille des polices de caractères,
et de quantité de données nécessaires pour trouver
et stocker une police dans la mémoire d'un ordinateur.
Le nombre de polices disponibles
dans votre programme typographique était limité.
J'ai procédé à une analyse des données,
et découvert qu'une police serif typique
que vous voyez à gauche
représentait presque le double de données
qu'une sans serif, au milieu,
à cause de tous les points nécessaires
pour dessiner les courbes élégantes des angles d'empattements de la serif.
D'ailleurs, les chiffres en bas de la diapositive
représentent la quantité de données
nécessaires au stockage de chacune des polices.
Donc, la sans serif, au milieu,
sans empattements,
était beaucoup plus économique,
à 81 pour 151.
Je me suis dit : « Ah ah ! Les ingénieurs ont un problème.
Appelons le concepteur à la rescousse ! »
J'ai créé une police serif, à droite,
sans empattements arrondis.
Ils sont polygonaux, faits de segments de droites,
et d'angles chanfreinés.
Et voilà, aussi économe de données que la sans serif.
Elle se nomme Charter, à droite.
J'ai présenté au chef des ingénieurs
mes chiffres, et j'ai déclaré fièrement :
« J'ai résolu votre problème. »
Il a répondu : « Ah ? Quel problème ? »
Moi : « Eh bien, vous savez, celui
de l'énorme quantité de données nécessaires aux polices serif. »
Il a dit : « Oh ! On a résolu ça la semaine dernière,
avec une routine de compactage
qui réduit la taille des polices par un ordre de magnitude.
Toutes les polices que vous voulez
sont dans le système. »
J'ai dit : « Eh bien, merci pour l'information. »
Encore raté !
J'avais sur les bras une solution
pour un problème technique inexistant.
Mais c'est là que l'histoire devient intéressante.
Je n'ai pas jeté mes dessins
dans un accès de déception.
J'ai persévéré.
Ce qui avait débuté en exercice technique
était devenu un exercice esthétique, vraiment.
Autrement dit, j'en étais venu à aimer cette police.
Peu importe ses origines. On s'en fiche.
J'aimais ce dessin pour lui-même.
Les formes simplifiées de Charter
lui conféraient une qualité évidente
et une retenue sobre
qui me ravissaient.
Vous savez, à une époque d'innovations technologiques
les concepteurs veulent être
influencés par l'air du temps.
Nous voulons réagir. Nous voulons être poussés
dans l'exploration de la nouveauté.
Charter est vraiment une parabole pour moi.
En réalité, il n'y a pas eu de lien tangible et immédiat
entre la technologie et la conception de Charter.
Je n'avais vraiment pas compris la technologie.
Elle m'a bien suggéré quelque chose,
mais elle ne m'a pas forcé la main,
et je crois que cela arrive très souvent.
Vous savez, les ingénieurs sont très intelligents,
et malgré quelques frustrations
car je suis moins intelligent,
j'ai toujours apprécié travailler avec eux
et apprendre d'eux.
A propos, au milieu des années 1990,
j'ai commencé à parler à Microsoft
des polices d'écran.
Jusque là, toutes les polices pour écran
avaient été adaptées de polices d'impression existantes,
naturellement.
Mais Microsoft avait bien anticipé
le mouvement, la ruée
vers les communications électroniques,
vers la lecture et l'écriture sur écran
reléguant l'imprimé au second rang
en importance.
A ce moment, les priorités n'étaient qu'émergentes.
Ils voulaient un petit ensemble de base
de polices, non pas adaptées, mais conçues pour l'écran
pour contrer son problème :
la résolution grossière de l'affichage.
J'ai averti Microsoft qu'une police conçue
pour une technologie particulière
était une police à l'obsolescence programmée.
J'avais déjà conçu trop de polices
dans le but de remédier à des problèmes techniques.
Grâce aux ingénieurs, les problèmes disparaissaient.
Ainsi que ma police.
Ce n'était qu'un palliatif.
Microsoft a répondu que
les moniteurs d'un prix abordable
à meilleure résolution
n'apparaîtraient pas avant une dizaine d'années.
J'ai pensé alors : 10 ans, c'est pas si mal,
c'est mieux que du palliatif.
Donc, j'étais persuadé, convaincu,
et nous avons créé ce qui allait être Verdana
et Georgia,
pour la première fois, travaillant non sur papier
mais directement sur écran, à partir du pixel.
A cette époque, les écrans étaient binaires.
Le pixel était soit "on" soit "off".
Voici le contour d'une lettre,
le H majuscule,
c'est la fine ligne noire, le contour,
qui est le moyen de le conserver dans la mémoire,
superposé à l'image numérique,
la zone grise,
qui est ce qui apparaît sur l'écran.
L'image numérique est tramée à partir du contour.
Avec un H majuscule, fait de lignes droites,
tout est quasiment parfaitement synchronisé
dans le système de coordonnées cartésiennes.
Pour le O, c'est une autre histoire.
C'est plus de la maçonnerie que de la typographie,
mais croyez-moi, c'est un bon O en image numérique,
pour la simple raison qu'il est symétrique
à la fois sur l'axe x et sur l'axe y.
Pour une image numérique binaire,
on ne peut pas demander mieux, en réalité.
Il m'est arrivé de concevoir, je ne sais pas,
3 ou 4 versions d'une lettre difficile
comme un « a » minuscule,
et de prendre du recul pour choisir la meilleure.
Mais, il n'y en avait pas,
alors le jugement du concepteur intervient
pour tenter de décider
laquelle est la moins mauvaise.
Est-ce un compromis ?
Pas pour moi, si vous travaillez
au meilleur de ce que la technologie vous permet,
bien que ce meilleur
soit loin de l'idéal.
Vous voyez sur cette diapositive
2 polices numériques différentes.
Je pense que le « a » en haut
est meilleur que le « a » en bas,
mais ce n'est toujours pas génial.
Vous pourrez mieux voir l'effet
si c'est réduit.
Ou pas.
Je suis donc un pragmatique, pas un idéaliste,
par nécessité.
Pour certains tempéraments,
il y a une espèce de satisfaction
à faire quelque chose qui ne peut être parfait
mais qui peut être fait au meilleur de leurs possibilités.
Voici le H minuscule en Georgia italique.
L'image a l'air dentelée et grossière.
Elle l'est.
Mais j'ai découvert, avec l'expérience,
qu'il y a une inclinaison optimale
pour l'italique à l'écran
donc les fûts sont bien divisés
aux limites des pixels.
Regardez dans cet exemple, aussi grossier soit-il,
comment les branches droite et gauche
se divisent au même niveau.
C'est une victoire. Là, c'est bien.
Et bien sûr, aux plus basses résolutions,
vous n'avez pas vraiment le choix.
C'est un S, au cas où vous en doutiez.
Alors, cela fait 18 ans maintenant
que Verdana et Georgia sont sorties.
Microsoft avait complètement raison,
cela a pris 10 bonnes années,
mais la résolution spatiale des écrans
a bien été améliorée,
et la résolution photométrique encore plus
grâce notamment à l'anticrénelage.
Donc, à présent que leur mission est accomplie,
est-ce la fin
des polices que j'avais conçues
à l'époque pour des écrans moins précis ?
Vont-elles survivre à ces vieux écrans
et au flot de nouvelles polices Web
apparaissant sur le marché ?
Ou ont-elles établi leur propre
niche d'évolution
indépendante de la technologie ?
Ou alors, ont-elles été absorbées
par la tendance typographique dominante ?
Je n'en suis pas sûr, mais elles ont bien tenu le coup.
18 ans est un bon âge pour n'importe quoi
avec les taux d'usure actuels,
je n'ai pas à me plaindre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)